what's going on guys this is rob and
welcome to halloween week here at comics
explain now for those of you guys who
are new Halloween is the time of year
where by we transition our stories we
try to stay within the confines of our
normal schedule but we transition to
stories that deal a lot with the spooky
element you know of Halloween that deal
with zombies monsters different things
like that and last year when I had run
over this there was some interesting
stories that I did like Jesus hate
zombies but there was also more
traditional stories that I did like
Marvel Zombies and things like that and
so as I was going through or as I was
trying to figure out what I wanted to do
initially I wanted to do the long
Halloween the problem is that it's 13
issues long it's massive in size and so
that's not really something that I could
do with any real measure of quality over
the course of like a day and so that'll
probably be something that I have to do
next year but I wanted to delve into the
realm of spawn now I've done spawn
before I think I did a little spawn
explaining video it was a one-shot I
guess like a one-off and I never really
got back into it again but when I was
going through and I was looking at spawn
I was faced with the dilemma do I want
to go through and rehash the first six
issues again which I've already done
which so many people are familiar with
or did I want to try something different
and so what I did is I went out and I
grabbed spawn the undead now for those
of you guys who don't know spawn the
undead is a 9 issue limited series but
each issue is a one-shot and so it tells
its own self-contained story not only
that it gives us a depiction of Al
Simmons within the realm of Image Comics
as spawn and shows us where he stands
now we'll get a little more into where
he stands with regards to the story as
we progress through it because this is
one of the cool things but this story
initially opens up with a guy by the
name of Travis Ward
now Travis Ward seems to be in a very
panicky situation that's one of the
things that I like about Paul Jenkins
writing here is he provides us with a
sense of dread a sense of foreboding
things are moving really fast you can
almost hear Travis Ward panting as he
runs so on and so forth
but he takes up refuge and in a Chinese
restaurant called long Duk dong and what
we learn is that he's actually meeting
with a woman named Sheila now it seems
at least from what she's saying the two
of them had not talked for quite some
time and in fact Paul Jenkins gives us a
little bit of a backstory here
especially with regards to Travis
himself what we learn is that
his arrival in talking with Sheila that
the first thing he does is he looks at
her hands he says I want to see your
hands now we won't find out why until
the end of the story but Sheila is
trying to figure out what's going on
with Travis you know for her Travis is a
longtime friend
he seems very panicky very jittery and
Travis of course says I'm in trouble and
what he tells us is that when Travis was
younger when he was in his college years
that instead of being a typical student
that went through and studied for
whatever major he was going in that he
ended up falling into the realm of the
occult now with regards to the spawn
comics and this is something that I
really want to get into here religion
does not exist
exactly in the same context that were
used to the characters of Satan and God
are very much real now we didn't really
know that Satan was Satan with regards
to these spawn comics all we really knew
was that there was a guy named male
Bhoja and that seemed to be the head
honcho running everything in hell it
wasn't until later on that we actually
learned Satan was an actual entity not
only that God and Satan are not the
absolute rulers of existence so to speak
in traditional religions and even among
Catholicism Christianity there's even
their subgroups that differ in their own
overhearing beliefs but the common theme
or at least the core theme seems to be
that you know it's somewhere along the
line God was just there God made all
things in existence you had heaven so on
and so forth you've had angels and Satan
rebelled against God out of pride Satan
was cast out some angels went with him
and the war between the two of them
stretched to earth over men's souls
that's more or less than just behind it
with regards to spawn it's not that way
yes those two still exist but the
conflict between God and Satan is really
more kin to sibling rivalry and what I
mean here is that within the spawn
comics there is a character or an
individual called the mother of
existence it's neither male nor female
but it appears as both depending on who
it is that it's talking to but the
mother of existence effectively is the
creator behind all things so the mother
of existence really plays the role of
you know the prime mover or something
like that and spawn universe but God and
Satan are only two of a pantheon of
beings that exist that were created by
the mother of existence the issue is
that much like almost any sibling
the two of them began fighting with one
another they began bickering back and
forth ultimately it led to an all-out
war between the two of them this war led
to earth itself whereby God created men
and then Satan gave man free will and so
in order to bolster own sides they both
have lieutenants they both have their
own soldiers and so on and so forth but
Satan wanted to bolster his army further
and so what Satan did if Satan created
what are called hell spawn which is
exactly what spawn is and these hell
spawn serve the purpose of traveling to
earth and tracking individuals who have
made deals with the devil
and then taking those individuals back
to hell in order to serve as part of
Satan's army now with regards to Travis
Ward himself the issue that he faced a
dilemma that he faced is that for the
individuals that he associated with as
part of the occult for them it was just
a passing thing it was just a phase in
college right because in college this is
how it isn't you know I mean not
everybody practices the occult but in
college you just find a myriad of
different things that's what is for
colleges a place where you go and you
literally figure out who you are you
join different things someone who is the
high school football star you know may
turn around and become part of the Chess
Club in college is people just figuring
out what their life is what direction
they're going in and who they are on a
fundamental level while a lot of those
individuals who were part of the occult
alongside Travis went on to do other
things the issue was that while Sheila
did this Travis did not Travis did not
let the occult go because for him he
wanted to see how far down the rabbit
hole he could go he wanted to see how
deep it went and the result was that he
ended up summoning a demon now with
regards to the spawn comics the demons
of Hell seem almost identical to uh
Inferno as it was written by Dante
Alighieri in' now for those of you guys
who are not familiar with the Divine
Comedy by Dante Alighieri what happened
here is he was a guy who claimed that he
had been taken on a journey through hell
and then purgatory and then finally
heaven and as he depicted Hell you had
nine circles at the top the the first
circle of hell was your average sinners
the ones who just sinned against God at
the bottom in the ninth circle were
those who were
treacherous you know explicitly I guess
Judas Iscariot who betrayed Jesus a
couple other people both of whom we're I
guess all of whom were forced to reside
alongside Satan himself and so with
regards to this story it seems as though
we're seeing the exact same thing in the
sense that this demon named named hak
Adama
that was summoned by Travis was of the
third circle of hell and what had
happened here is Travis wanted to know
everything he could or learn everything
he could with regards to Hell itself as
well as effectively how to be immortal
and so what Travis did is he struck a
pact Travis said that he would sell his
soul to this demon for everything the
demon knows and so when the when the
deal was struck when the pact was made
Travis said I want to know how to escape
damnation and so this was basically
creating a scenario whereby a pact was
struck and then Travis was given
information on how to escape that pact
now what the what this demon does is it
basically refreshes us on the character
or spawn again you know more or less
talking about Hell spawn different
things like that
talking about how those things function
talking about the the rivalry between
God and Satan so on and so forth but
more so than that it tells us that when
when a hell spawn goes to take someone
who's sold is going to be claimed by a
demon due to the fact that they struck
that there seems to be no escape under
normal circumstances there's no escape
the only way for Travis to avoid going
to hell is to figure out where it is
that his gate to hell is going to be and
then avoid going there now what we'll
learn at the end of this is that these
gates take many forms but for the sake
of this discussion this segment of the
discussion right now it almost seems
impossible to know this but what Travis
is also told is that there will be
something called an usher and this uh
sure will effectively be this hell spawn
and Travis tells this to Sheila right
you know he tells her that according to
all the reading that he's done according
to all the studies that he's done that
these Usher's are basically hell spawn
now he doesn't really know he doesn't
really you know know about spawn himself
in terms of Al Simmons you know Travis
Ward is just looking at all this from
someone that has no real clue of what's
going on with regards to the bigger
picture for him is really just armchair
philosophy there's
real actual involvement here he's just
going by stuff that he's read somewhere
and so for him he says there are Usher's
these Usher's are basically Hellspawn
when a person strikes a deal with a
demon or the devil themselves when the
when the time comes for their soul to be
claimed these Usher's go and find those
people and bring them back and that's
why I say the spawn is different because
spawn when he was created when Al
Simmons became spawn when the deal was
struck that he would be able to return
to death or we return to earth after its
death he was supposed to serve this
purpose that's the entire basis behind
spawn within the first 60 issues that's
what you learned that he was supposed to
be a hell spawn he was supposed to take
the souls of the Damned back to hell so
they would become part of Satan's army
but then he went rogue and chose not to
which is where the violator came in and
the violator was designed for the
purpose of basically forcing spawn to to
either follow the instructions of the of
mal Bhoja or exhaust all his power and
be forced to return to hell anyway and
so for Travis war he's basically
explaining all this stuff to to Sheila
and Sheila says look this is absolute
insanity what you're talking about here
is complete and total nonsense not only
that she doesn't believe it she doesn't
believe any of it and what she said is
what evidence do you have to make this
claim that there's a hell spawn out
there Travis not only produces a
document to her with regards to a
painting that was drawn but he starts
talking about how he saw his hell spawn
now this Hell spawn is spawn it is Al
Simmons but for him he says that
everywhere he went after this after his
time had basically come everywhere he
went everywhere he traveled to every
step he took in the shadows was spawn
waiting for him waiting to claim his
soul and send it to hell and so what
happens is Travis goes back to this
demon goes back and and basically says
look like this this hell spawn is coming
for me it's not my time yet how do I
avoid this hell spawn how do I avoid the
Gate of Hell that I'm supposed to go to
and again this demon says there's no way
for you to know there's no way you could
possibly know what this gate is going to
be you know you could very well be swept
up in it and have no clue it's happening
until suddenly you arrive in hell and so
you know the question that Travis has is
okay then fine then is there a way for
me to locate this gate and this demon
says no the demon itself doesn't know
what the gate is the only person who
knows
where this gate to hell is is spawn
himself and so this is the situation
that Travis explains he basically says
hey look I don't know what's going on
here I don't know if somebody can help
me I don't know if there's anything you
can do you know but before he really
even gets into an explanation of why it
was that he called Sheila here she
ultimately decides to stop listening it
says hey look like I can't follow this
anymore I can't listen to this anymore
like I don't know if it's drugs I don't
know if it's alcohol but you got to go
relax you got to take a cab home just go
home sleep on it and everything will be
fine and so what happens is you know he
gets in the cab and begins his journey
and we find out that Sheila was actually
spawn the entire time not only that when
Travis you know when when Sheila had
asked the question but what makes you
think that you know what keeps you from
believing that I'm spawn you know that
I'm a hell spawn if all this is true
what keeps you from believing that I
would be the one that would just sweep
you up and you know Travis says well I
checked your hands and this is where
things begin to come into play because
what Travis had told Sheila was that
whenever hell spawns appeared they
always appeared immersed in red and
black Sheila was an african-american but
she also wore a red cloak and that's how
we knew or at least suspected that
Sheila was spawned now some of you guys
may have picked that up already some of
you guys may have already guessed the
ending of course Sheila was spawn but
the fact remains here that the cab
itself is the gate to hell the cab is
going to take Travis Ward directly to
hell that in truth there was no way for
him to know that this was going to be
the case but it shows us how this works
it shows us that some people are just
taken directly to hell and they have no
idea that it's actually going to happen
it's just one of these one of these
these weird things but if you guys enjoy
this because I'm kind of uh I mean I
really like this it's a little
unsettling to be honest it kind of you
know makes you adjust in your seat a
little bit like this is weird you know
but it's also a really really good story
and I really enjoyed it but if you guys
want to see some more of these one shot
to drop a like if you guys want to see
some more of this stuff make sure you
guys hit the sub button to become part
of the Rob core if you're new to comics
explain and leave a comment down below
let me know what you guys thought about
spawn the undead because I think it's
pretty solid again these are all just
one-shot stories or self-contained
stories so with that being said we're
going to bring this video to an end
uh yeah I will catch you all later peace